one of the two of you can tell me about
how your editor helped you make sense of
all the footage I know you spent like
five or six years with him and we're
very close to the footage and close to
him as well how did your editor really
help shape the film yeah it was really
an important process as you say we we
spent a long time filming with Chris
lots of different pieces we went through
a lot of his archive so there's a lot of
raw material there too
to piece together into a cohesive story
we work with two editors Michael Ugland
and Aaron Wickenden who were fantastic
editors and it was so useful to have
them come in with a little more distance
from the material than we had because
we've been so close to it for so long so
to get there sort of fresh eyes on the
project and helped us really you know
figure out what was important to go in
there and what wasn't and help shape
that story they they were fantastic
thinking it was a really important part
of the process of making the film how
much footage did you have of course over
the years I suppose yeah it's hard to
say in terms of like specific kind of
hours and things but you know the film
took shape over a number of years
because Chris's sculptures take a long
time to come together
he works on these things for a number of
years and you know before they sort of
come together into a finished piece so
our process was visiting him
periodically at his studio checking in
on what he was working on and trying to
you know trace the development of
different pieces he was working on so so
we ended up with a lot of footage with
him shot at his studio we also filmed
installations and openings of various
pieces and then there's a huge amount of
archival material as well he opened up
his archives to us so we went back in
that to not only find documentation of
his performance works in his earlier
works but we also did a lot of digging
outside that to find interviews with
Chris from earlier periods in his career
to try and really bring those time
periods to life as well as well as other
related materials so yeah it's hard to
give a specific number but there's um
yeah there's a lot to work with there so
so again working with our editor
and working together to try and make
sense of that and pick what the
important products were was some was it
was a big process but um yeah we thought
it went really well it was excellent by
the way seeing him with regis philbin
and it was really sort of interesting to
see both those worlds contrasts you know
I'm wondering how you viewing Chris and
his work has also shaped your work how
you view artists in general because he
was so different for his time have you
felt more of a freedom in your own work
or you were just so enthralled with
Chris that you just sort of you know
focused on him but it had it changed
your view of art in any way or what you
do working with him I think
getting a first-hand view of his process
was was very important and he was very
patient and I think a idea that came out
a lot was that sometimes with patience
and a process that takes a long time
things can come out of that where you
you go down a path that's unexpected
you make a discovery that's unexpected
and and that happens over the course of
years so I think my takeaway and
influence from Chris's work is really
just how important the processes and
that patients can really be a virtue in
art yeah I would absolutely agree I
think that was that was a really
interesting thing to learn about and I
guess one other thing that I found quite
inspiring about Chris once we got to
know him and dig into his um his art was
just that his his commitment to the work
you know whether it's his early pieces
where he was often literally kind of
putting his body on the line to explore
an idea that was interesting to him or
his later pieces which as I said could
take many years and a lot of investment
of you know both time and money to sort
of bring together often he started those
pieces without a clear idea of exactly
where they would finish or you know if
they would end up in an institution or
bought by a collector or something like
that so he really had a lot of
dedication to his art a really clear
vision of what it was he wanted to do
what she stuck to
and that was really interesting and
inspiring I think I have a quote from
Chris and he says that I don't have to
make an object to have it the art the
performance itself could be art so since
he sort of lived in public when you say
his whole life was pretty much sort of
an active artistry in some sense I think
that you it's possible to make that
argument for the first part of his life
but I think there's a real line for the
second part of his life where that's not
the case and he became a very private
person and there was a real separation
between his private life and his public
life in his life in the art world and I
think Chris really valued that and I
think the work benefited from it as well
I don't think doing the performances he
did and having the blur between his
private and public life was long-term
sustainable for him or anyone it was
interesting to see him yeah who sort of
Topanga Canyon property and how at one
point it seemed like he didn't want to
leave I think you alluded to in the film
and that he felt safe there and you know
I found that fascinating in that because
he was so polarizing to those in the art
world do you think that was part of why
he stayed he felt more protected there
he could control what happened you know
I think it's probably fair to say or I
would think that that you know the way
that he did become more private in the
second half of his career
is probably a reaction to you know his
time doing performances whereas which
said there was this real blurred line
between his his public life in his
private life but I think that you know
once he moved up to Topanga you know he
brought some land up there in the late
seventies early eighties and over time
built up a studio and a home up there it
was just a place where he was really
comfortable and it was kind of his place
to experiment with new ideas he was
always really interested in what the
next project was he was focused on what
he was doing next and and you know got
so immersed in that and excited by that
so I think it was a place where he just
felt really comfortable to experiment
with new art
works and to pursue the things that were
most interesting to him it was very
comfortable and creatively you know free
place for him how would you compare
Kristen's life in the 70s to todays
selfie culture vloggers where we all
essentially in the modern world living
in public and desire to do so how do you
I mean he was kind of doing that all
before it became yeah it's interesting
yeah I think I think that elements of
what he was doing then are a precursor
to what you see now I mean he did some
pieces where he took control of TV in
that um he would put his artwork you buy
ads based on TV and broadcast his
artworks there you see one right at the
start of our film and that was really
exciting to him you know the idea that
he was sort of pushing his art into a
non art context and reaching a new
audience with it
and I suppose in a lot of ways that what
he did them was kind of a precursor to
what you see in the culture more broadly
now but he was also criticized for that
ad wasn't he in some sense yeah I think
that people to a certain extent felt
slightly well some people felt a little
bit sort of attacked by it that they
weren't expecting to see this artwork in
metal suddenly watching TV and this
thing pops in their face but I think he
enjoyed that that element of it as well
and that reaction to it
you